So we can technically use the mean integrated square error or
AMISE to select the optimal bandwidth for a kernel density estimation.
However, for general kernels, this is very difficult to estimate.
So the first rule of thumb is given by Silverman's Rule of Thumb.
This works only for one dimensional data.
The optimal bandwidth is given by H, which is four times sigma raised to
the power of five, divided by 3n, the entire thing to the one fifth power.
In this case sigma is the standard deviation of the distribution.
In this case, the kernel is also assumed to be Gaussian.
A more generalized way to obtain a bandwidth is given by Scott's Rule.
This shows you the formula to obtain the general bandwidth in D dimensions.
For a one dimensional case, we put D equals one.
In this case,
the Sigma here shows the covariance matrix in the D dimensions of the data.
In fact, when we determine the kernel density estimate of our data here,
we used the Scott's rule to find our bandwidth.
All the different factors we obtained was simply some fraction of
the bandwidth obtained using Scott's rule.
Notice we also used the Gaussian kernel here to get the KD.